unter CDU-Chef Friedrich Merz ist bei
uns im MoMA herzlich willkommen Herr
März wir haben sie gerade gesehen ihr
Auftritt bei Markus Lanz da haben sie
von kleinen Paschas gesprochen was für
ziemliche Aufregung gesorgt hat manche
werfen ihnen Populismus vor manche gar
Rassismus bedauern Sie die Wortwahl wir
haben eine interessante Diskussion
geführt bei Markus Lanz und ich habe
nach dieser Sendung eine für mich völlig
unerwartete Zustimmung bekommen zu den
Themen die wir da besprochen haben und
deswegen muss ich sagen es war wirklich
eine gute Diskussion ist aber auch eine
notwendige Diskussion dass wir uns über
die Frage unterhalten was läuft in
diesem Land eigentlich schief das haben
sie ja in der Sendung angesprochen und
da hat glaube ich auch niemand was
dagegen aber ich kann schon verstehen
wenn Menschen sagen dass die
Formulierung kleine Paschas und sachlich
ist verallgemeinernd respektierlich
provozierend und sie sind ja ein
erfahrener Politiker sie wissen ganz
genau dass sie für so eine Formulierung
an den Stammtischen Applaus bekommen
aber auf der anderen Seite andere
Menschen
studieren und natürlich damit überhaupt
nicht zur Lösung des Problems einer
fehlenden Integration beitragen das sehe
ich anders wir haben in den Schulen
erhebliche Probleme in den Schulen haben
die Lehrerinnen vor allen Dingen aber
auch viele Lehrer Probleme
anerkannt zu werden bei vielen Schülern
und es sind dann oftmals auch Schüler
aus
Migranten Familien und über diese Themen
müssen wir diskutieren was in der Schule
schief läuft kann man hinterher in der
Gesellschaft kaum noch wieder
korrigieren und deswegen habe ich den
Zusammenhang hergestellt der mir
übrigens bisschen meinen Wahlkreis
hinein und das ist ein sehr ländlicher
Wahlkreis das ist keine Großstadt das
sind keine Brennpunkte in meinem
Wahlkreis von Lehrerinnen auch genauso
gesagt worden ist und das mache ich zum
Thema sie glaube nicht dass sie mit so
einer Formulierung Feuer ins Öl Gießen
Öl ins Feuer gießen also wenn dann Öl
ins Feuer ich wundere mich über manche
Äußerungen und wissen Sie wenn dann Jens
Spahn der das gleiche gesagt hat wie ich
vor wenigen Tagen aus der SPD heraus als
Nazi bezeichnet wird dann verlässt das
den Boden einer vernünftigen
demokratischen Diskussion als sie mal
als cdu-vorparteivorsitzende angetreten
sind haben sie gesagt sie möchten die
Wahlergebnisse der AFD halbieren das ist
bisher nicht gelungen wie wollen sie das
schaffen wollen sie die CDU inhaltlichen
Tick mehr nach rechts rücken vielleicht
auch mit solchen Vorstößen wir werden
die CDU jetzt neu positionieren in
zentralen politischen Fragen wir fangen
heute Abend den Leipzig mit einer
Klausurtagung des Bundesvorstandes an
wir werden bei diesem Bundesvorstand uns
vor allen Dingen mit dem Thema
Wirtschaft Energie und Klima
beschäftigen ich möchte dass die CDU
ihre wirtschaftspolitische Kompetenz
wieder zurückgewinnt ich möchte aber
auch dass wir Wirtschaft Energie und
Klima nicht mehr als getrennte Themen
bezeichnen und betrachten sondern als
Einheit und daraus werden wir dann in
acht Punkten mal konkrete
Schlussfolgerungen ziehen also ich
möchte die CDU wieder in den Sachthemen
auf die Höhe der Zeit bringen wir sind
in einen Sachthemen zurückgefallen und
dazu zählt auch das Thema Klima aber
eben auch Energie und Wirtschaft und das
sind die Themen mit denen wir uns heute
Abend beschäftigen und morgen früh wir
haben eben in unserem Beitrag gesehen
dass sie gesagt haben ihr politischer
Hauptgegner sind inzwischen die Grünen
ein Kernthema der Grünen ist die
Klimapolitik was hat denn die CDU in
Sachen Klima den Wählerinnen und Wählern
anzubieten was die Grünen Ihnen nicht
anbieten zunächst einmal sind es nicht
unser Hauptgegner sondern unsere
Hauptwettbewerber ich spreche nicht
gerne in diesen Kategorien von Freund
und Feind und wir haben in der
Energiepolitik in der Wirtschaftspolitik
und auch in der Klimapolitik zum Teil
ganz andere Vorstellungen als die Grünen
wir sind keine verbotspartei sondern wir
sind die Partei der sozialen
Marktwirtschaft und unsere Antwort wird
sein die Probleme die wir heute haben
sind entgegen allem was da geschrieben
und gesendet wird aus unserer festen
Überzeugung heraus mit
marktwirtschaftlichen Instrumenten
lösbar nicht mit Verboten sondern mit
ermöglichen mit Anreizen mit Ermutigung
mit Ermunterung mit Forschung mit
Entwicklung auch dieses große Problem
vor dem wir stehen die Menschheit steht
ist erstens nicht aus Deutschland heraus
alleine lösbar es ist auch nicht mit
Vermeidung alleine lösbar es ist noch
nicht einmal lösbar mit Recycling und
Wiederverwendung möglicherweise sogar
der Speicherung von CO2 wir werden uns
auch mit der Frage beschäftigen wie wir
denn mit dem Klimawandel leben können
und müssen so und da eröffnen wir
erweitern wir unseren Horizont und wir
gehen nicht so eng und verengt allein
auf Regulierung und Verbote und das
unterscheidet uns ganz fundamental von
den Grünen wir sind uns in vielen Zielen
einig aber auf dem Weg dorthin trennt
uns vieles noch mal kurz zu ihrer Rolle
als
Oppositionsführer wir haben in der
Sendung schon über die aktuellen Zahlen
des neuen ZDF politbarometers berichtet
da liegt die Union mit 27% zwar vorne
aber diese Zahl die wir hier Ihnen
zeigen wollen ist auch interessant die
Bundesregierung macht ihre Arbeit eher
gut sagen 53% Prozent schlecht sagen 41
Prozent also die Mehrheit findet die
Arbeit der Bundesregierung gut und
cdu/csu-geführte Regierung würde es
besser machen sagen nur 21 Prozent also
nur rund ein Fünftel damit können sie
nicht so ganz zufrieden sein oder bin
ich auch nicht mit zufrieden aber das
ist ein Bild was wir in Umfragen immer
haben es gibt eine gewisse
Konzentrierung des Meinungsbildes auf
eine Regierung und die Zahl die mich
mehr interessiert als diese Zahlen ist
die Tatsache dass die SPD als die Partei
die den Kanzler stellt in den Umfragen
jetzt auf Platz drei liegt mit 18 %. er
wundert hat es in der Geschichte der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland noch nie
gegeben dass die Kanzlerpartei unter 20%
liegt und auf Platz drei im Vergleich zu
den anderen Parteien das Meinungsbild
differenziert sich weiter aus wir haben
den Anspruch Volkspartei zu bleiben und
diesen Anspruch einzulösen wird schwer
sein aber ich werde alle Kraft daran
setzen das hinzubekommen und bei 27%
manche sehen uns schon bei 30 30,5 das
ist ein gutes Plateau eine gute
Ausgangslage aber daran müssen wir
arbeiten wir wollen dann noch besser
werden wird ja auch ein politisch
interessantes Jahr mit mehreren
Landtagswahlen und die cdu-klausur heute
mit inhaltlich die Weichen stellen das
war Friedrich Merz der CDU Vorsitzende
vielen Dank danke